A solution that provides the best of both
worlds is called finger tables, where every node
knows m other nodes in the ring. And
the distance of the nodes that it knows increases
exponentially. So, for example, node 10 would maintain
mappings for 10 plus 2 to the 0, 10
plus 2 to the 1, and so forth, where finger i Points to the successor of n
plus 2i. So finger 0 would point to the successor of 11, which is 32. Finger 1
would also point to 32 and so forth. Finger 5 would point to 43. Now every
node knows it's immediate successor. So what you
want to do, is find the predecessor for a
particular ID. And then ask for the successor
of that ID. So let's suppose that node 10
wanted to look up a key corresponding to the id of 42. It can use the
finger tables to find the predecessor of that node. Which in this case, is 32.
It's finger tables have the mapping of that nodes location as well. It then, can
ask, node 32, for it's successor. At this
point, we can move forward around the ring,
looking for the node, whose successor's ID is
bigger than the ID of the data, which
in this case, is node 43. Due to
the structure of the finger table, these look ups
require order of login hops. This results in
efficient look ups, order log in messages per
look up. And the size the finger table
is order of login state per node. Another consideration
that we have to take into account Is what
happens when nodes join, and leave the network. When new
node joins, we first have to initialize the fingers
of this new node. Then we must update the fingers
of existing nodes, so that they know that they
can point. To the node with the new ID. And
finally, the third step is to transfer the keys
from the successor to the new node. In this case,
the key that we must transfer from the successor, one is the data with ID
of 54. In this case, each node's successor
is maintained and the successor of any particular
ID k is always responsible for k. A fallback for handling leaves is to ensure
that any particular node not only keeps track
of its own finger table, but also of
the fingers of any successor. So that if a
node should fail at any time, then the predecessor node
in the ring also knows how to reach the nodes
corresponding to the entries in the failed nodes finger table.